- This morning we had one of
the most iconic moments in Tea
With GaryVee history that I
genuinely believe will help tens
of thousands of people
over the next decade.
As this gets populated sit down,
get some popcorn, really pay attention.
- Holy shit man, I'm fucking nervous man.
(laughs)
- Don't worry bro, we're friends.
- Like shaking and everything.
I've been watching you
for like three years dude,
my wife is watching, my mom
is probably watching too
so what's up guys.
- Awesome.
- Damn Holy shit.
- Don't worry bro.
- Trying to be a man, trying
to be a man here you know
(laugh)
- Bro It doesn't take a man,
a man owns his emotions.
I'm a man out here
talking about compassion,
sympathy, kindness and love.
So I'm proud of you for
talking about your nerves.
I just want you to hear this clear,
you can't imagine how
nice that makes me feel,
I'm super flattered.
- Awesome, I'm so glad, man.
- Its humbling.
- You really do change
people's lives, dude.
Like I'm sure you know,
but like it's like to a
whole different level.
- Thank you, bro.
- So I'm 22, I'm married.
I've been married for like three years,
I just had a baby, couple
of like you know, January.
- Congrats.
- So I'm pretty fulfilled in that sense,
you know what I'm saying?
But one thing I've always loved
to do since I've been like 13
is like make YouTube videos.
Just because like I have had
rough patches in my life,
when I was younger,
watching people on YouTube,
like you know, entertaining people.
Like that's always been
like, I'm like, wow.
Like you know, it's
always made me feel good.
Like I wanna do that for people too
and like my thing is like, I love cars.
Like I like racing, I like you know,
building race cars and shit.
Like I have a YouTube
channel, it's been up
for like four years but I've
been so inconsistent you know,
like I upload and then I delete it,
'cause I think the videos
aren't good enough,
you know, just like really negative
and then that's when I
started watching you,
when I was in tech school.
I feel like I went to tech
school and I did all that just
to prove myself and you know,
just kind of be like, you know,
I'm not as bad as people think, you know,
especially when your
family says you're bad,
it's kinda rough to deal
with that, you know.
- It's extremely difficult.
- So.
- It's really tough.
- Yeah.
- Go ahead.
- So I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna do this.
I graduated with a 4.0,
which I know in tech
school it's like, nah,
it's only a year and a half
so it's not like too big
of a deal but I tried my best.
- Bro don't undermine your success.
- Yeah, I know.
Just some people like, I'm sure like,
Oh that's not that hard.
- Bro the biggest issue out
of your mouth is the word Some people.
- Yeah.
- Bro, you have to stop giving
a fuck about these people,
in the comments and the
ones that are watching.
- Yeah, that's true.
- I always listen very carefully
and just like you hedging the 4.0,
based on some people is
the biggest thing we need
to work on on the next
91 years of your life.
That's where you're at, we gotta fix that
and when I say fix that,
that feels too heavy.
You need to get into a better
relationship with that.
- Right.
- Everyone's always gonna have an opinion.
- Yeah, no, I mean that's 100% true.
Everyone always has something to say just
to kind of lead up to, you know,
what I think about myself,
like in the sense of,
so like I'm a very negative person,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I'm a negative nasty kinda guy.
Like literally I wake up in the morning.
- You're cynical, like you
wake up and you're cynical.
- Yes, like I wake up and I'm like,
what can go wrong today?
You know, because I've tried
so hard to (Gary interrupts).
- You're not ready for this,
you're not a negative person.
You're a scared person.
- Yeah, I could definitely
(Gary interrupts).
- Alexis, That's a big difference, bro.
- yeah.
- For all the people out
there that are watching
that are scared and fear
based and vulnerable,
you're not negative,
don't demonize yourself.
You're actually vulnerable,
you're not negative, bro.
- I didn't think about
it like that actually.
I never thought of it that way.
- That's why we're fucking
doing Tea with GaryVee.
- Yes, yes that's why I'm glad
to be on here 'cause
I needed to hear this.
- And let me tell you why
this is important, Alexis,
all of a sudden when you wake up tomorrow
and you realize you're not a negative,
when somebody thinks
they're a negative person,
that's devastating.
- Yeah.
- You're like I'm bad.
No, you're not bad, you're hurt.
- Yeah.
Yeah, maybe it was something
that happened to me.
You know what I was younger or something,
you know, just kind of
like sets that you know,
what's like, what's gonna happen today.
You know, like it's such a
bad, but like I feel like
that affects me with everything I do
because like (Gary interrupts)
- Of course it does.
- When I'm making YouTube videos
or like when I'm doing stuff like that,
I'm kinda like, you know,
like, Oh this is gonna be trash,
like this isn't good
enough, like you know,
just like, I don't know.
I put myself down a lot
and I'm just like, my original
question actually is nothing
with what I'm talking about, you know.
- Bro, this is the real shit and like,
we're here, I'm with you right now.
I like this talk right now.
I really, really, really
like this talk right now.
I think you're helping over
the next 10 years 'cause a lot
of people will watch this
video, not when we record it.
You're about to help a lot
of people I can see in the comments.
You literally just helped
a lot of people just in
that one moment so let's keep going.
I'm telling you that your
self esteem is vulnerable
because to your point,
you said it earlier,
when your family tells
you, you're not good,
you believe that shit.
- Yeah, yeah 100%.
- We need to get out of that.
Does your family still say that?
- So like as soon as I
started watching your videos
and I know you say not to do this
as much but I feel like, you know,
I just tried to cut
out negative people out
of my life and just isolate myself.
Like I do this a lot.
I've actually never had
any longterm friends.
Like I've never had a
friend that I can be like,
Oh, I've been best friends
with this guy for a long time.
I think my best friend right now,
I guess is like, I've
known him for like a year.
You know what I'm saying?
Because like, as soon as
like someone does something,
I feel like it makes me feel negative.
I just kind of like isolate myself
and I push everyone away,
you know what I'm saying?
Like (Gary interrupts).
- Of course, 'cause
you're emotionally soft.
- Yeah, yeah I can see that.
- And your Mendoza line
for cutting someone off is super l&ow.
Like for me, my Mendoza line's super high,
like you have to really,
really, really go somewhere
and I've had a lot of things done to me.
I had a friend in college
who stole my "Second Genesis"
and I still was friends
with him after I found out.
- Holy shit.
- Because I knew he was in
a bad spot to do that to me,
I was in a rugged college.
But other people I know cut people off
because they said something.
- Right.
- The reason you don't have
longterm friendships is
because of your own lack of self esteem
and your inability to rise
above when somebody goes low,
- That was gonna be my thing.
Like I said, I've been
watching you for a long time
and I know like you know, you've,
actually I was worse than that.
To be honest like.
- I believe you.
- watching you,
has made me better, like you know,
more confident in myself
and more like you know,
I can deal with that kind of stuff more
but I feel like it takes a long time too
because even in three
years of watching you,
like, I'm still not where I wanna be if
that makes any sense,
like I'm still, you know,
not like mentally where I
wanna be and just stop being
so negative and I wish,
and every time something
good happens in my life,
I'm always like, okay,
what's gonna happen now?
Like ask, you can ask my wife.
Like I don't get excited
when good things happen
because I automatically
think something bad,
is gonna happen right after.
- Bro I live with this,
my father's got a lot
of these similar traits, bro.
- Holy shit, so (laughs).
- I understand you.
- Is there any way, like I can, you know,
like get better at that?
- Yes.
- You know, like (Gary interrupts)
- Of course you just said ,
you got better the last three years.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I feel like I have, like,
I feel like I've gotten better
at like stop fearing about
what other people think about me.
That's like a big thing for me.
Like I've gotten way better at that.
- You know, you see how
you've got some muscle?
- Yeah (laughs)
- How'd you do that?
- Oh yeah, I worked out,
played football in high school, yeah.
- That's how you do this.
- Yeah.
- Listening to positivity,
owning your shortcomings,
accept that you know,
the reason I'm talking
with such candor here, you know,
I'm sure some people are watching like,
damn Gary's like exposing
his shit, I'm not doing that.
- I mean, I like it, I love it.
It's awesome.
- 'Cause it's empowering when
you own your shortcomings,
if you can't own your
fucking shortcomings.
Well then you can't
talk about your strikes.
What I think is keeping me
here with you is my deep belief
that you're on your way because
it's about awareness fact
that you have the strength to come on here
with all these people watching
and talk to me like this,
actually makes me believe
that you're well on your way
because I know a lot of people who don't.
- Yeah, I'm just like trying to like,
you know, like it's such
a bad thing in my life
that like, it's like a mental block
for everything I do that and it's like,
man, I need to stop doing that.
- You need to realize that you're not bad,
you grew up being told you
were bad and you believed it.
You need to realize you're
not bad, you're scared.
- Right.
- The second you go from, I'm a bad guy,
I'm a tough guy, I'm a negative guy
to I'm a soft guy, I'm a vulnerable guy,
I'm emotionally like not
where I need to be guy.
All of a sudden, the way you
even look at yourself changes
and then you could start focusing on,
building those muscles on that.
- Right, Yeah.
- Do you get this feeling
that you cut people off
because you don't feel like,
you get into this place
where you feel like they're
pulling one off on you
and you don't like that feeling?
- Yes, like I always think
somebody has an angle.
Every time someone's nice
to me I'm like, okay,
what's your angle dude? Like,
what do you want from me?
You know what I'm saying?
- Did you feel that way about me,
the first time you saw
the content potentially?
Like what's gonna be the other shoe?
Like, is he gonna try to sell me a course?
Or what's the fucking punchline?
- Surprisingly, I feel like
I didn't just because like,
you know, like you were so honest
that I feel like you wouldn't
be the type to do that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you were just being like straight up,
like authentic and honest.
- And maybe that's 'cause I was remote
and through (Alexis interrupts).
- Right.
- The screen instead of real life.
- possibly, possibly.
- you know here's where I'm
trying to get you to go.
You need to get into a
totally different place
with your self esteem,
you need to love yourself.
That's why the biggest moment
of this talk was you're not negative
you're just vulnerable.
That was the biggest moment
because when you wake up
and you're like, I'm scared today
and I need to get less scared today.
That is huge, huge compared to waking up
and saying I'm negative, I'm a bad guy.
That's a game changer Alexis,
that's a game changer.
- Yeah, it's like hard though.
Like I try to, I really, really
like there's a lot of times
where I'm like, okay, like
just stop thinking like that.
You know, like you got this, you know.
- No you have to understand
it's ingrained in you
so what you need to do is practice.
What do I mean by that?
The next, this one friend
you've got right now for a year,
the first time he does something
that doesn't pop off
properly, you have to fucking,
you have to like email me or DM me
or watch this video game,
you have to forgive him.
- Right, Yeah.
That's yeah, not hold grudges.
(laughs)
- Bro grudges are garbage.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Grudges are fucking garbage.
- Grudges are the execution of a weak man.
- Yeah, no, I agree 100%.
It makes you just, you know,
makes your life quality go
down when you hold grudges.
- Is your wife positive?
- Yes, she's like the
complete opposite of me.
But like, I feel like I try.
- It's such a cliche.
- To put her down though.
Like, I'm that bad that like.
- Of course you do.
- I try to be like her, you know.
- You're not that bad,
you're not the bad, bro.
I'm telling you right now if we change,
the terminology in your
life shit will get good.
You're not that bad, you're that weak
you're that scared, you're that soft.
- I totally agree with you honestly.
- Bro, it's a big, I wanna
change your vernacular
because if you do, you'll
be a different man.
- Yeah.
- It's that when you're most scared,
you try to bring her down to your level.
- Yeah that's exactly what I do.
That's why when you say,
you talk about like haters,
you know, like trying to
bring other people down,
I'm like I'm that guy.
- Do you find yourself like being jealous,
if like another guy looks at her?
Like, are you trying to like cage her?
- No, not like that actually.
Like I'm not like bad like
that but I'm bad in the sense
of like, when she's like
trying to be happy for me
for something that I
accomplished or positive
or she's positive about something.
- You know like don't
do that, don't do that
because I'm gonna,
something's gonna happen
and then I'm gonna let you down
and that's gonna make me feel
like 100% (Alexis interrupts)
- Yes like that's my fear.
Like to let my son down, let her down.
Like, I'm always like in
that (Gary interrupts).
- Bro, bro, listen to me the
only thing that you can do
to let them down is by
continuing down the path
of thinking that you're bad.
- Right, yeah.
No I, yeah I can't, I don't
want him to grow up like that.
You know, like being like me,
like I don't want him
to (Gary interrupts).
- Of course you don't.
But let me tell you
because I've watched this,
I've watched this transpire
'cause I'm old for 44,
I got some real fucking emotional wisdom,
what's gonna end up
happening is if your child
or children end up having
similar DNA to you,
you're gonna feel so bad
that you're gonna actually resent them
and have like a worst rela...
Like you'll have a good
relationship with the children
that take your wife's DNA and
you'll have a bad relationship
with the children that take your DNA,
'cause it's gonna be painful to you,
'cause you're gonna be
like, fuck, I passed
that on to her or him so I'm out.
- No, I really...
- You can't do that.
- I know.
- Okay, yeah.
- Bro I'm really proud of you
to be at this place at
this young of an age
to be self aware enough
to know what's brewing
and to have the courage to come on here
and talk to me about this
shit, that's game changing.
When I tell you you're
close, because the only thing
that holds people back is hiding shit.
- Right. Right.
- And right now you just
told tens of thousands
of people about your shit.
- Yeah, yeah It's just like
that bad dude that like,
I'm like, I have to tell
someone that actually like,
you know, 'cause I got to tell
other people like my wife,
when I say other people,
I mean like my wife,
she's just like, I feel like
maybe hearing it from her,
is not as good because I'm like
of course you're just gonna try to like,
you know, bring me up
and make me feel better,
'cause I'm your husband, you know?
So of course like, I feel
like her answer is not
as genuine maybe,
but it probably is.
- Doesn't carry.
- I just automatically think that.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Listen, you default into
the angle, the conspiracy,
you must love conspiracy
fucking documentaries.
It's like, that's like, you know,
like that's where you're at.
- Yeah.
- And then what's so
interesting in the theme
of the show is now you
know why you're the one
that looks at other things
and tries to tear people down.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's all the same game, I really believe
as we go through this period
of time in American history specifically
and really in the world where hate
and negativity have definitely risen.
- 100%.
- I believe that we're gonna
get into mental health issues
and get into, you know,
parenting structures and like
what I'm really worried
about is that a lot of people
that think they're kind and
good people are actually,
shaming people instead of trying to help.
- Right, yeah I agree
with that, I think...
- Of course you do.
- I definitely agree
with that.
- You're on the receiving end of that.
- Yes, yeah (laughs) yeah.
I think I gotta like work on it more like,
on a daily basis and
just exercise it more.
I don't know, I didn't think about it.
Like I'm scared of stuff, you know,
I just thought about it
like, I'm just negative
you know like, I just don't
like people that much, you know.
- No, no you don't like yourself.
- Yeah, yeah I know that's probably,
- Bro, you don't like yourself
- I hate,..
I really don't like how I am.
Like, I hate that mindset that I have
- That's right but the good
news is you can fix it.
I didn't like that I didn't
have you know, muscles
and that you know, like,
and that I was not healthy
for my heart and like I was
gonna die like and I changed it
and when I tell you working out
and eating right did not
come natural to me at all.
So I changed, I figured it out.
I got a babysitter, a trainer
and I figured out the system,
you just have to figure out your system.
Maybe you have to listen
to positivity on podcasts 24 hours a day.
- That's right Vayner.
- For five years.
- I listen to you every single day,
like all time like
that's (Gary interrupts).
- And other people too and I appreciate it
but like, you know, like, bro,
you have to watch this
video like every day.
- Yeah, no, I probably
will dude this is like,
the biggest moment ever, I told my wife,
this is like top five like,
best things like in my life.
- Bro, you are just perfectly cliche in
so many of your actions.
I see so many young people
who have this framework, get married early
as soon as they find
somebody super positive.
- Yeah, yeah it's like I
didn't even realize it.
- You thirst.
- Yeah.
- That's right thirst for her.
- Yeah, yeah. I really,
I tell her all the time,
like I wish I could be like you,
like I wish I could just think
everything's gonna be fine
and like, you know, like
I always tell her that,
'cause it's just such a good,
you know, like (Gary interrupts)
- And instead of making
it selfish and say,
"I wish I could be like you,"
maybe what you can do
is make it a compliment.
You're making it about yourself
when you say that to her.
- Oh shit.
- But You might wanna change that to,
and this is where
semantics of words matter.
Maybe you say to her, what's her name?
- Noemi.
- Noemi, I admire your
optimism and positivity.
Now all of a sudden you're
giving her a compliment
because when you say to her,
"I wish that I could be like you,"
she's not taking that as a compliment.
She sees that as you being selfish about
what you wish, you're
about you in that sentence.
- Yeah, that's true.
Yeah I'm saying I wish I was, you know?
Yeah.
- And what you're doing
is you're subconsciously,
again saying, hey, like, feel bad for me.
- Right.
- Instead of propping
her up you're asking her
for another hand, there's a
subconscious guilt of like,
you got lucky with DNA, I
didn't and what's gonna happen
with her is she's gonna build
resentment for you over time.
- Right.
- Bro, I really, really believe in you.
- Thank you, man.
I appreciate it like, you know,
I don't normally talk
about this with anyone.
You know normally, like
I tried, like I said,
like only with her, but I was like, man,
Gary's like the perfect
person to just put this on,
you know and just see like what, you know,
what his response would be.
- I swear to God on everything in my body,
I genuinely think you can win this game.
- Thank you, man I really
like it's life changing
to hear that from, you
know what I'm saying?
Like it's (Gary interrupts).
- So please realize that you were wounded.
You're hurt, you're not bad,
you're good with an injury.
- Right, yeah I just didn't realize that.
I didn't think about it, I didn't,
you know I guess, i guess
'cause I'm young too
so I kinda like, you know,
think about that stuff.
Like, you know, and now I'm like, damn,
that's probably what it is man
if something happened to me,
you know like it just kind
of like started from that
- Yeah listen and by the way don't
and I don't think it's, usually it's more
of a systematic you know, culture.
Like it's very likely that one
of your parents is exactly the same way
and instead of resenting your parent,
you can feel bad for them too.
- Right.
- You can have compassion for them instead
of now going into a places
like, you know what?
Fuck you, mom Gary is
right fuck you, no,no,
you can go into a place of compassion
because it's likely that her mom did that
or your dad's dad did
that or do you understand?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- You need to realize
that you're strong enough
to change it for everyone
digging in and drawing a line
and making it a fight is gonna do nothing.
- Yeah, and you think like also like
what you surround yourself with
also kind of affects you too
kind of like (Gary interrupts)
- 100%.
- Right.
- It's why I fucking work so hard
to put out so much free content.
I'm trying to be a
positive force for people
that aren't fortunate
enough to have something
and I have a unique communication style
and a human element that
clicks for some people
that because I think
they can taste the lack
of interest of anything
other than you know,
like I'm not looking for anything.
- I agree 100%, that's what I said,
when I first started watching your videos,
I didn't think like you've had an angle.
Actually like I was like,
Holy shit this guy is like,
and I think it's 'cause you
call people on their bullshit,
you know?
And like, that's why I said
like (Gary interrupts).
- You know it's funny, you
know, it's funny I hear
that a lot from people and they like that,
you know what's funny?
I think even the tone
of this conversation,
I just wanna help.
- Right, like I said, even in three years,
I feel like I have gotten better.
You know, maybe I've
gotten worse actually at
that isolate people, like
myself from people more.
But I have gotten better
in the sense of like,
you know, now like with YouTube
and like other stuff like
that I'm more confident
that I will be able
to make that work you know,
like that's like my thing that
I'm like (Gary interrupts).
- You need to realize that
those people aren't bad
or have an angle, it's that your scared,
'cause you're not emotionally
strong to be let down.
- Yeah.
- You're cutting them
out to protect yourself.
The way to really win
quote unquote is for you
to get comfortable with being let down
and realizing that's
not a reflection of you,
- Right, no, I agree with that.
That's that's awesome, that's
like what I needed to hear.
- I'm glad I could deliver it Bill
- Thank you so much, man.
I really, really appreciate it, dude.
- Lexis listen to me over the next year,
a million people are
gonna watch this video.
Just remember that means
that cutting people out
or trolling someone or waking up,
like you're not gonna be able
to live anymore tricking people,
you're not tricking anyone anymore.
- Right.
- Use that as a positive.
- Yeah I need to change,
I need to do something like
I can't keep being like this.
This is (Gary interrupts).
- I'm telling you right now
what most excites me is I know you can.
- Thank you so much.
- If you knew the power and
strength it took for you
to be honest on this
video, now living life
and being okay with Ricky
if he like steals your money
or like says something bad about your wife
and you being a bigger part,
like you can't imagine
now trying to forgive one
of your parents or an uncle or something,
you know, I don't wanna dive too deep.
It might be something even more extreme,
than just a negative atmosphere.
There might be some real deep shit,
forgiveness is the fucking
key to a whole new life.
- Yeah, no, I haven't
practiced that yet in my life.
If you know, like I haven't really,
I'm not a forgiveful
person, so maybe I should.
- That comes out of your own insecurity.
- Yeah.
- Forgiveness and being the bigger person
and kindness is the
fucking ultimate strength.
- Yeah, no it's, yeah I need that.
I need to do it, I need to start doing it.
I really do, I really do.
- I believe you, I really think you can,
I really think you can that's
why I'm five minutes late
for a huge client meeting.
- Oh my God, dude am so sorry.
- No, no, no, you're not, no, no.
What I want you to hear is that
the reason I'm this late is
because I feel this moment so
much and I'm also super aware
of how raw and real we
went and how many hundreds
of people right now watching
or living your exact life
and this, this thing I
genuinely believe is the seed
of so much of the things that
are anxious in our society
and I desperately, desperately
want to be one of the forces
to fucking help cut this
thing out of our bodies.
- Yeah, no, I mean, we need it,
you know, like for
people that are like me,
like you know it's like
(Gary drowns his voice).
- Alexis, you have an Instagram.
- Yes.
- 'Cause I want this community
to DM you, encourage you
and I want you to make
some positive friends
- Thank you so much.
- What's your Instagram?
- It's @alexiscisnero yeah, right there.
Somebody found, Dustin found it, I guess.
That's awesome, Holy shit he's fast.
- All right, you're at 567, 568 Now.
- Oh, dude thank you so much.
- You like cars?
- I love cars, that's been my passion,
since I was like six years old.
- Alright 568 Vayner Nation.
This would mean the world to me.
I wanna see this number
completely fucking explode.
I want every one of you to DM
this man something positive.
I want Alexis please.
- Thank you so much, I appreciate
that so much, Gary, man.
Thank you so much.
- Lexis, listen to me,
please do me one honor,
Please listen to this whole entire thing,
I think it was like 30
minutes often, often.
- Okay, thank you so much, man.
- Like literally work out every
morning and listen to this
or while you're brushing
your teeth every morning,
every morning, I'm telling you, man.
- Yeah, thank you so much, dude.
I will listen to it.
I mean, trust me, this is
like a huge deal to me.
Like I said, top five like
life moments and you know.
- It's a huge deal for me too.
- Thank you so much.
Holy shit, like I didn't, I
honestly wasn't even gonna talk
to you about this, like I was like,
I had a whole different question
but then I was like talking
to you and I'm like,
damn, like he's actually
like as real as it gets, man.
You know, so I was like,
you know I'm just gonna
let it all out you know.
- Alexis, you helped more people today,
than most people ever get to
help in their entire life.
You're a good kid.
- Thank you so much.
- You're not negative, you're not bad.
You're mislabeled, bro.
- Don't make me cry, dude.
Like (laughs) Holy shit this is like...
- Bro, you are mislabeled.
You're mislabeling yourself to yourself.
- Yeah.
- You're a wonderful fucking
human who has an injury,
has a vulnerability and has
to completely address that
and change the way you talk
and think and practice that.
You want a real prescription?
Go reach out to everybody in your phone,
go to your phone right now
and look at it from A to Z
and text people and say,
you're sorry and I love you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That takes real strength.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah there's some
people that I'm like,
dude, I would never even wanna
see this guy's name again.
You know, like I don't know why.
Like it's, yeah (Gary drowns his voice).
- Because you're insecure.
- Yeah.
- And when you do that, if
you get the courage to do it,
when they reply, fuck you understand.
- Yeah.
- Compassion comes from enormous strength.
- Thank you so much, man.
Like I said, this moment right here,
I think it's definitely
100% life changing for me.
This is definitely like I said,
I've been doing better
in these last three years
but I feel like it's just that boost
that I need 100%.
- Thank you so much, bro.
- I'm proud of you bro.
I love you a lot , good luck.
- I'm so sorry.
Thank you so much, man I love you too.
- Sorry for what?
- Sorry for you being late (chuckles) 10
or nine I didn't even notice it's time.
- This is the best nine
minutes late in my entire life.
I'm so humbled to have
this moment with you.
What we just did here
will forever bring value
to human beings, I
believe it in the depths
of my fucking being.
- Thank you, that's like
that means a world to me.
That honestly really means
the world to me, dude.
This is what I needed.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome brother.
- Have a good day, man, thank you too.
- Bye. Bye.
- Dustin, that really
matters, that last one, man.
- Yeah like (Gary interrupts)
- That's the whole game,
that right there is the whole
game I see in the world.
- I feel very similar like there's a lot
of people in my world
that I've kinda dropped
and I've wanted to reach
out but I'm just afraid
that they're gonna be like...
- Fuck you.
- Fuck you or like whatever
loser or something like that
and I just don't know how to handle that.
- Don't do things for
other people's reactions.
Do them for you and for the karma
and even if they tell you,
fuck you they'll always know
where you stood 'cause right
now they think you stand
with fuck you and you might
be doing a blessing for them
because that may inspire them to do it
for somebody else even if
they don't reply to you.
- Yeah.
- There's nothing more
noble than I'm sorry
(exhales loudly)
(sniffles)
- And if you can do it
in an audio or video
where they can not lose the
tone of the written word,
it's even more powerful, man.
Dust, you can do it, bro
you're here with me now.
Like, come on, you can
do that, you should.
- Yeah, you're right.
- It's good, putting out
more good is good you know.
It's what we fucking need,
man this is it's time.
We've gone too long with not
making this the way we go.
You're gonna feel lighter.
- I mean I did start, like I
had someone sent me something
to like make fun of
someone and I was like,
I DMed them like, hey, someone sent this
to me to like, make fun of you
and I was like, no, I'm not doing that.
Like I actually respect
what you just put out
so I just want to say that
and any bad tastes you have
about me from the past,
I just wanna apologize for that too.
Well he never replied,
but at least I tried.
- That's dude no, no ,no not tried,
executed you're not doing
it for him to reply.
You brought value to him and
you brought value to yourself.
You won with that I'm
so proud of you, man.
That's humongous.
- Thanks.
- Write down the list
from fucking AA to ZZ,
in your address book, write down the list.
- A lot of people (laughs).
- Listen, that means you were hurting.
- Yeah.
- I know you well enough to understand it.
Do it, it's so nice to do, it's so good.
You're a different man now.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] See you tomorrow
on Tea with GaryVee.